all right let's try c5 why not did I put
my preferred as white is that what it is
I have to change my settings off to look
into that okay we have the Alpen
alrighty then let's go with this
typically not a good idea to bring the
Queen out so early but a little
different seeing that this night will
not be able to play to c3 with tempo at
least not right now it could end up in
that situation after there's an exchange
on d4 but we have yet to cross that
bridge ok let's get this [ __ ] about and
then this these two moves at least in my
mind take a precedence to the Queen
night coming to c 6 because i want to
make certain that i could be replying
you know well I don't want d5 to be
played like a c4d five type of thing my
night if I develop my queen night
prematurely to that c 6 square could
eventually get kicked away with the c4
or d5 and in both cases those moves are
coming with tempo so I think I do this
right now or do I now I'm going to take
first if I played this there is pon
takes and I'm not really able to get
that pond back because of the tension
between the Queen's if I play d 6 in
pond takes if Bishop takes pawn there's
first Queen takes Queen and only then
Bishop takes bishop I'm down a piece
okay let's do this and now in response
to night here I could be pinning it and
I might just want to run right away with
that right away with that there should
be four move okay it's not happening
just yet more development if castles I
still might want to play here let's
let's do this if a three is played back
up yeah let's do this if be four is
played okay i'm not watching over this
anymore but maybe i could be targeting
this pun now queen is hit just clean
here a good idea or die just take that
night i'm going to take the night get
castled so this is a hanging pawn
structure for black can see this for
both sides not necessarily out of this
opening but I've seen the hanging pawn
structure for both sides i guess you
could say that would any structure but
in how hanging ponds C&D pond could be
targeted by both rooks rugby eight-hour
rugby one is met with v6 in most cases i
have to watch about a couple things when
the rook plays to be one it's not just
hitting the pond but threatening for
maybe rook here hitting my queen and
bishop for example if i played my night
here and the rib plate here i have to
come home with my queen to defend the
night not really a fan of that so let's
let's do this v6 later on
hmm later on I might want to do this
night move I do weaken this a a 6 square
which could certainly play a role where
I got my queen d 7 or d 8 or D 6 yeah
none of none of the above there let's go
with D 6 pressure on this pawn i also
want to stay out of the way of a 95 move
with the tempo directly on my queen and
that that would be the case if she was
on d 7 additionally if I came all the
way back if night played here then
there's Knight takes Knight type of
stuff going on and again there's still
tension going on with this Bishop
indirectly and this rook directly I
could play Knight a5 with tempo and do
that right now clean here rook da
now let's see my truck involved this rut
goes here the other one goes here and I
guess you could pretty much say that
when you're going against when you're
faced against what when you're having to
play against that's what I meant to say
when you're having to play against the
hanging pawn structure having both rooks
pointing right at them probably a good
idea ah now that oh that's a pain that
is definitely a pain c5 is ready to be
played how annoying I would like to take
this night and then pond but after the
recapture my rook is in trouble oh this
is trouble you know what I have to go
back and now what I want to do is be in
a position to me pond push with the
night here but guess what that's not
happening I take care and then get my
rook here I wanted to do a move like
that so that my night would be in a
position to watch over b6 okay let's go
this pond is hit twice defended 0 this
pond is hit once defended 0 may seem
weird to view things like that or you
know voice my thoughts in that way but I
do it for an important reason something
that I devoted a whole video too not
that it's like anything elaborate but
just having to do with unprotected
pieces and stuff like that helps with
knowing what might be in trouble
right here seems like a good move I
might be getting myself into a pin or I
might not be let me let me do this that
pond seems like it's gonna fall there's
maybe even some Forks no yeah actually
if pond takes I'll take with the night I
think and then at least my rook could be
plying to one of these two squares c3 to
hit this pawn c4 maybe to hit this one
but we have that instead okay this is
weird all right how about this I have
the possibility for a six and then be
five I think again again it'll get
undermined though if a six rupee 5v5
there's a four there isn't this rook is
protected so there's not really a way to
exploit this pin I don't think they're
all of this really isn't a pin on takes
I'm just really not liking that oh I
could take here when I see that sooner
could take here I'm hitting the rook
rook here and then I just come back and
try that wine i see that sooner let's
come back here so that's officially upon
grab right there accomplished nothing
more than just gobbling up on i think i
can get away with it though so that rook
and rook here I guess okay now I'm
getting another pond here take on this
square and then take on c5 I have a
flight square for my king g7 is there
down to the wire King up only move
okay right here my I have my rook
covering this square and get that pond
pushing and keep pushing and get right
behind that passed pawn let's do this
move just to stop Bishop here from
getting adam King position last but not
least actually pawn position my pond and
night are constraining that King a real
lot I could take this bishop I like my
night better than the bishop I'll take
it on the next turn maybe watch out for
the bishop moves there's no time sneak
that king over all right time issue good
game let's back up let us back up here
flip that board I think there was a lot
of a lot more pressure maybe that could
have been placed on me and I could have
really been in trouble I really do feel
like I I could have been in bigger
trouble right here so where is there an
improvement i'm i'm liking these moves
that were played by light up into this
point i don't see anything wrong with
that in fact this is this is really good
I'm h3 I view it as a flight square more
long-term and I view it as setting black
up for potential problems on this fifth
rank as soon as rook be one is played
and as was played in the game Rick b5 I
have to be very cautious of the Queen
and the bishop being on this rank so rip
their queen here defends how about this
maybe this is a slight improvement Queen
a4 just so you're not having to deal
with tempo sort of stuff maybe Queen a4
right aways now if it wasn't thought
about you know maybe that's another one
you could be considering i like the c-4
move and i don't know about this right
here i was thinking about
oh no well I had his response okay if c5
I was anticipate I was going to be
playing night d5 so Bishop here was
interesting you have the bishop pair i
have a lot of pressure on the ponds but
you take out that night and you get in
c5 so I was saying that I thought there
was something much better or something
like that where is this other line here
oh maybe just keeping the Queen's on
yeah i think if you could keep the
Queen's on and maybe get that c5 move in
it be better because my queen is a
little bit lost I think it's easier for
white to have a nice home for their
queen than it is for my queen to have a
home but maybe that's another way you
could kind of view this so maybe queen a
four instead of Queen the b3 keep those
Queens on and then still run forward
with this c4 c5 idea and that will
undermine my night I really can't rely
upon that I can't rely upon that a five
square for too long so maybe that's
maybe that's a better one to go with
it's kind of tough here I guess isn't it
because of the pressure on here and then
the a pond etc so maybe trying to keep
that Queen the both Queens on in that
structure will benefit white that's a
generalization can kind of go with or
play around with at least okay my
opponent says thanks for the comments
you are welcome thank you for the game